let me finish oh my god she looks
terrified oh my gosh okay after a long
hiatus and a couple of one-offs potato
mode is officially back for I guess what
you'd call season two I'm your host John
Luke and I am joined today by max hello
and we are playing as I'm sure you can
tell apex legends I it's got a good
artistic art style I really like this
game it does look really good especially
high settings on PC yeah which is what
we're playing on right now we got the
settings maxed out we're dropping hard
oh we're you dropping by the way so this
is harvester it's usually sort of spicy
but we'll see I mean you guys want to
like get back into it because console
play has been not so graphically
intensive and it's not like the high
refresh rate and oh I bet James yeah
we're gonna give max a little bit about
tuning and warm up and and for people to
see how good this game looks Oh
excellent
oh that's gonna be a short one probably
nice Oh
oh my god wow that was close good
robbery yeah this is a nice looking game
honestly it is a nice looking game oh I
forgot that you could like show off the
gun model yeah and it like takes off the
hutt too which is really nice and very
cinematic oh I can't wait yeah we're
about to destroy that okay so I think
we've sufficiently shown how good the
game looks on PC and Mac settings let's
get into those settings options and just
just crank everything whoa oh boy I want
to see how this looks cool okay all
right all right you're just starting to
see a little bit of them crispy yeah
crispy texture ease here I know I mean
we're getting into streamer territory
here this is how they place they get the
max performance out of their computer
that is fair but a life lines pants are
looking already a little mushy okay I
wanna I want you to do one more thing
for me okay I want you to go into the
resolution I want you get as low as you
possibly can oh boy all right we're
going to gameboy advanced mode yes all
right okay oh there we go
all right all right impacts legends
available on ps4 Xbox one PC and Game
Boy Advance dude this was a Game Boy
Advance game holy [ __ ] to be so far
ahead of its time I love it
cool so okay so he pushed the game to
its natural limits now we're gonna push
it to it's unnatural limits yes all
right here we have potato mode secret
sauce the Nvidia profile inspector we're
just gonna go ahead and change a couple
of settings on here to really just
absolutely annihilate these graphics
okay
my favorite is how any sort of particle
physics just turn into school it's so
good it's like this feature like the
cinnamon Listerine strips oh yeah oh
look how like there's like a portion
that goes upwards offer her like her
make offers yeah she went ham a Sephora
my favorite part is how like for some
reason here
just always disappears but when you
click on it you can see it for like a
split second a bun would be but it's not
there anymore that's so good
all right who else we have oh these are
uh these are terrifying looking looks
okay it's fine yeah that's because it
does another face like weirdly looks
less ugly than when we had it before
because it before it compressed all the
textures right now we just removed them
all and they just look like a round they
match and they look really shiny cost
okay okay that's actually terrifying
what have we created without guns how do
the guns like let's see no colors that
is an untextured gun model that's great
I love it well let's hop into the game I
think okay I like how underneath of life
lines drone is just a whole bunch of
rectangles the smoke it's just all
squares
everything is squares that is actually
the most terrifying thing I've seen in
apex legends and this is not the bald
skin this is actually just that's just
your default right yeah okay so that's
skin is hair that's weird
oh yeah that is kind of weird it must be
not considered hair oh my gosh there's
like it's just like two colors and
that's it
well we're gonna play for as long as we
can we possibly might get banned again
it's always kind of a gamble when you
modify online games don't try this at
home by the way yeah this is definitely
not waiting for the textures to load in
and they're just not know I mean there
is Poppins but no it's not this is uh
that's cool has a lighting effects going
on yeah and the Lighting's not gone
which is still impressive oh whoa look
at that there's like a square around the
Oh interesting
I wonder why is I is that like the range
that you can I don't know I think so
actually
hmm that's weird all right and wonder
what that means
look at the road this is really good I
love this so far I need to get a shield
battery and I'm gonna charge this thing
and see the animation for it okay Wow so
the sky is okay in the background is
okay still and that much it must be a
flat texture it must be yeah yeah I can
sort of see them ish oh this is bad
though the lstart shots oh my god the
blood - that is like more distracting
yeah I think it is I can't see much with
like this I was curious if you're gonna
have an advantage or a disadvantage I
feel like you're at a disadvantage I
feel like I am - I like held like this
syringe is just like pumping squares
into my wrists we need to see how that
works oh my god so many squares there's
so many squares that looks cursed yeah
oh that's cool that's really funny
wow there's so much smoke effects oh wow
yeah that is like obscuring bugs
yeah pixels and squares I feel like this
is definitely disadvantage because if I
was in the middle of that and I saw that
I won't be able to see anything oh yeah
let's just go for it yeah look at
bloodhound squares everywhere yeah what
effect is that supposed to be uh it's
supposed to be like like spark effects
holy yeah just get right in there BAM
way oh no oh gosh I can't okay whoa
nice okay I feel like this is still
definitely a disadvantage right now
oh god no nice okay
I think it's a testament how good you're
playing you're just good at this game oh
no oh let me finish let me finish
oh my god she looks terrified oh my gosh
okay it's not looking good
not looking good at all the animation is
so cool though
okay okay that'll look really cool it
did look pretty cool actually
it's the faces man I can put the robot
or like a mask then it's fine but yeah
that's a face it looks like the curse do
the guns don't look half bad cuz they're
just untextured guns right honestly I
like how it looks from up here it's kind
of cool-looking yeah I'm down with that
it gives this voxel like simplistic
okay well that just yeah when you zoom
in like that now see it looks it's like
it looks better if you squint so many
squares this is this basically Square
simulator at this point
oh that like ooh a little reflection on
the Sun yeah that's real nice right
there ooh all right let's see how
remanence looks
oh that's cool that is pretty cool
actually although if I shot that now
shooting at somebody I would not be able
to see past that I think we've said this
before on potato mode but I feel like
I'm sort of getting like a small insight
into how games are like graphics are
done yeah how they're still modeling is
built well because like like here's a
good example where sometimes characters
their hair disappears and you know that
must be like a specific effect that
we're unstable
other times the hair doesn't disappear
and it's a more solid model pair so
depending on the character and how
they're designed yeah how their design
like some sometimes their hair is gone
and sometimes their hair is still there
I think that's really interesting so the
fence is completely see-through so
that's a little bit of an advantage
point well if I get banned
oh no way this is interesting
oh god I can't see any was that that was
a bloodhounds skin toasty in here I've
always I've always wanted someone to
like make actually a game inspired by
like the visual aesthetics of a potato
potato mode the game yeah I'll buy it
Oh whichever way you're going go back
for a second I want to look at the that
looks pretty good
he's uh oh you just can't see Wraith oh
okay well now you can see race hair
outline what we cuz it's the helices
it's the Ally outline yeah yeah but
there's still no hair on her just
there's just something about a potato
mode
Naruto running Wraith that just brings
new in my heart it's pretty good are you
gonna door block me I and I see how it
is to see how it is him cackling at his
desk right now this actually might be
the depths of Hell right here
not in doom eternal it's an apex why
your hands blue oh the skin like sure
he's just feeling blue abadeer but uh
I'm gonna go sit in the corner now let's
find out where these fools are whoa why
are the polls just blue okay I don't
know man I want to ask
oh he's gonna do it yeah that's so weird
I wonder why these lamp posts are blue
for no reason oh my god the leaf the
tree looks so weird
whoa that looks really cool and it's
cool-looking
oh there's a square in this guy yeah
it's like we're so good Oh
oh god oh god getting like some CRT
effects coming off of that ring oh yeah
it's like this weird whoa it's like a TV
band yeah I wonder if that's because we
don't have the aliasing on that's
possible so much you can't see anything
no man is like 19 different directions
like I can't see from oh dude the havoc
looks crazy
Oh see you can't see me buddy already
there they're seeing normally yeah I
guess so this is definitely a
disadvantage I don't know how people say
this is hacking oh no oh no what's going
on here what's happening
I can't what is happening that didn't
happen in the game did it guess I'm
curious what they saw okay was it the
just a coins yeah she's just a flat
pancake all right I start this party up
oh my gosh what happened to you man
it's just his arms on his head where
does body go this is great I love it
this is uh this is a lot I meant what's
up man
you know have a little dip hey how you
doing hey uh Moscow Mule over here all
right max thanks for joining and showing
off some apex legends potato fide I
think we have proven that it's not
really much of a gameplay benefit to
play this way about really it's maybe a
detriment you get like one benefit like
19 things that go wrong so maybe not
yeah all right well thanks for watching
everybody and if you have a game you
would like to see potato fide let us
know in the comments below and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]